okay well for people who are joining
this livestream this is a software
architecture internal design meeting
about a slightly complicated topic which
has to do with the way that entities
that custom entities are represented in
Wolfram language and in external
databases connected to or from language
so let's launch okay so let me try to
understand the context of all of this so
what we have right now we have um
entities that are just something here um
um
[Music]
we have entities that are associated
with our built-in entities like for
instance something like this right so
what is the relationship between and we
also have the notion of an external
reference what is the relationship of
what we're talking about here two
built-in entities
hello nobody so one of the things that
we want to do for the the SQL
integration is that we want to introduce
other primitives to perform more
powerful operations on external
databases and I think those operations
should also work on internal entities so
okay it's fully general okay but let me
try to understand
I don't know it's time to cook let's go
through the introduction here what what
is this about and what have we got -
last time we were talking about this
okay so this is so if you look at that
New York City entity the second moment
so the first argument tells you what the
type of the entity is yep I cannot even
tell you it's it's a unique identifier
yep so the question is how do we digest
unique identifiers to come from the
outside which are basically uu IDs
depends it depends well it depend on I
mean so we've got the notion of an
external reference is our own here
I assume Alamos here yes no he's not but
I can grab him yeah I would think so if
that's what we're talking about
will do
well the external reference is is used
for like currencies that are aligned
with other systems or yeah that's
correct okay so walk me through what
what what is the question here so okay
so okay so different database
administrator might have made different
choices on how to index these things and
so might be you IDs might be strings
might be successive integers it might be
might be dates as well okay but so each
one is associated with some particular
database schema is that true so whatever
scheme is being used is associated with
some database schema is that true yeah
okay and how are we representing the
database schema how we identifying that
by schema the database schema is
represented so if you if you got the
other file that I sent you via email
that's that book beans thought sqlite3
when we do if you do just database
inspect in isolation on that file what
am I supposed to do with that file okay
and put it in the same folder as this
notebook with that's called canonical
name is this folder is this folder been
put somewhere or is this folder just
sort of floating freely it's not gonna
put somewhere I'll put it somewhere um
can somebody remind me what folder we've
got stuff about this end this is what's
called databases okay
is there somebody from project
management here Dominique
whose hey analytic management I'm doing
okay
so you want me to put that put the
SQLite file in the same directory as I'm
putting this notebook
correct it would have been great if this
had already been set up
so we can I assume you you were running
a prototype build not right now I'm not
but I can if you want me to what should
I be running gostrey since you get okay
it's one that ends in three sevens is
that the correct one let me check
whatever this bill does it doesn't allow
that the welcome screen is broken here
does it allow cloud connection which I'm
probably going to need I look for this
okay all right so I will open this
notebook and
you
okay all right
now what do I do now do I run yours
first yes mine well see No well this
should probably be no I'm sorry
well nevermind it's gonna evaluate
another thing further down okay
and for reference Alan has joined great
oh by the way we haven't fully optimized
the connection to jatin yet so this is
going to take like in the meantime I can
explain to you the the basic idea of
what what we want to discuss today
okay okay so basically the main problem
is that there you don't always have a
guarantee that there is only one column
that that composes the the primary key
Frankie might be multiple columns and so
the question is what scheme do we want
to use to construct a canonical name out
of the primary keys whether it's a
positional okay but look in the end what
we're trying to do let's zoom out for a
minute
in the end what we're trying to do is
we're trying to map an external database
into an entity store yes in an entity
store there are entities and the
question is within a particular database
schema you say there are but there are
primary keys that are in that database
schema and the question is how do they
wind up as as reasonable as possible
entities in an entity store is that
correct yes so okay so you were asking
so this has finished evaporating so now
if you just out of that first gray cell
copy out database inspect then you can
see the our representation of the schema
which is yeah without the end you wrap
around it so okay all right so this is
okay so this is a schema it says it's an
SQLite database in this particular case
and has ten tables
okay you can open the Flipboard it's the
singular of the words schema schema the
singular scheme Artemus singular yeah
okay and scheme otter is the plural eyes
yes okay cool um and
if you look at these tables like for
instance editor you can see that there
is one field there which is a primary
key okay let's take a look okay so this
is opening Eddie thought and what's
inside um um okay let's take a look
okay can I get this out in some
structure that I can actually compute
with this yes certainly this is just the
bottom how do I get it out in a
structure I can compute with I mean it
has I don't know if how much we
implemented yet but it has probably so I
okay so this SQL database object has
properties which includes some
presumably data set hierarchical
representation of the schema is that
true we should do that this is nice and
um okay even if varchar' 40 is rather
grotesque yeah all right so fine so okay
yeah so so that's so now you have the
entries register as well from this data
SQL database objects by wrapping and
c-store around it we construct a bare
born entity store which has no planner
so this so this entity store will go
into the state-based schema and try to
construct sensible entities to represent
the primary keys in this database is
that correct yes okay an entity register
registers those entities within the
session so that I can just refer to them
by their name so how how would I do
discovery of you know some entities here
so for example I want to know about
editors that exist here can I just do
entity list and then what do I do
quotes editor like that yes okay and so
what it did was it took something I
might very well not want in the entity
registration or the entity store
creation and it now has an entity type
called editor that comes from the key
here and those are the names of those so
if I look at the input form of that what
I should see is entity of editor comma
blah blah blah okay and those those
things there were just the actual keys
that appeared in the state base is that
correct yeah those correspond to the
primary keys Stendhal ID in this case
since nobody has told us what the label
would be all those editors are remain
kind of nameless they of this ugly
strings okay so in the construction of
an entity store just so we're clear the
there are you can specify for entities
both the canonical name and a common
name or label is that correct yes in
this case the common name is not defined
well so let's so let's just see what
common name actually does so if I say
this and I say common name of that what
does it do look that's pretty horrifying
is that really the right thing
I don't know this is what and the entity
framework currently does it's out of our
I mean you haven't defined label so
there's nothing really we can do I don't
think this is the right thing to do for
that
Michael head can you comment on this I
think it's writing why because it this
is what it is like there doesn't exist
something outside of the name properties
that is common in Canada it is a higher
Auto object okay I mean the only thing
would be a kind of do something sensible
rather than having this kind of
grotesque thing hanging around
throughout your I mean it might help if
we formatted a missing better that would
probably make it less grotesque another
reason to do that it also indicates
what's that what is the only possible
day to fix the problem well fair enough
okay all right so let's come back to
what you were talking about before so
okay so now the question is suppose this
is a simple table that has only one
primary key so it's fairly obvious how
what to do but first of all tables can
have multiple primary keys but also as
soon as you start doing complex
operations on them then you might end up
with several primary keys or primary
keys that are not entirely obvious so
how do we how do we specify them and I
think that there are two possible
schemes and the one that is currently
implemented is kind of a mixture of the
two which are not particularly a fan of
and the two are one is positional
hierarchical which means that you
basically keep constructing nested lists
and then it's just the position in the
list that tells you what what is the
property that corresponds to any one the
other one is named that you construct an
entity ID wrapper and then in that
entity ID wrapper you have an
association or property goes to value
okay sorry um go ahead so I'm sorry you
have to repeat that so what I was saying
is that when you start constructing more
complex queries the primary keys will
also
change and so there are two possible
schemas in which to start constructing
more complex primary keys out of the the
existing query so for basic type there
is not much of question because it's
it's flat okay so just just to give me
some sense okay what are we trying to
achieve here so we've got do we we
discussed this before didn't we a little
bit all right so your point is that I
don't understand I mean the primary key
can have multiple columns there can be
multiple columns that represent the
primary key yes
so ultimately the entity has to have has
to be labeled not just by a single entry
from a single column but okay but this
is one were you using named things from
named columns this is something we're
just making a list of the things from
those columns is that correct yes
okay so this would be analogous to the
New York New York United States type
type deal just having them in a list is
that correct yes okay
well there's a caveat with New York
which is that cities and administrative
divisions can have lists there are
different lengths and this can't really
happen here but fine that's okay okay so
now the question is what happens when
you start doing operations on these how
do the primary Keys transform that's
really interesting question
well I don't know why would they
transform at all I mean an entity is an
entity with some canonical name well
let's go through the one very basic
example if you scroll all the way down
20 and rotate by you will see a couple
of examples and grab it by it was before
before I grenade okay okay so well the
first exam
the first two examples you can evaluate
when you look at this one here okay so
I'm trying to understand this one so
entity value as a entity aggregate by or
as a title a title are called title in
this database but they're books really
so and they have those types curvy
things like let's see okay so that's
fine so that that types there and it's
aggregating by those types but what's
this price per type third element so
that's that's you read in a value so in
this case basically you're you're
summing all the taking all the business
books and summing the prices
I understand but but why isn't entered a
aggregate by the aggregation it's like
is there an entity group by no not not I
mean we didn't call it group by because
it doesn't really have the same order
arguments that's good by well why not
because in group by you can get out a
hierarchical structure here you really
can't and also the the so in reply you
can just stop at the first two arguments
and and you don't need to aggregate the
things you should do that with SQL you
get nothing out okay although you just
get the type so there is no implicit
aggregation that you can do because
because SQL only support first normal
form and so only now you can't put lists
you need to sum or to take the average
okay but but let's let's go back in here
for a minute so what is the analog for a
data set for example of aggregate by you
can do it with group by it's more like
three why you basically it's like group
by where you will provide another
function that does something was the
result of the grouping and that function
was introduced namely this function read
the reduction function is that correct
yeah
you're also you'll also have to append
it to the original Association so that
it stays list of associations
oh wait a sec wait a sec wait I'm trying
to understand what is the relationship
between entity aggregate by and group by
so if I understand it group by
here has let's take a look I mean so in
this case if I say group by four this
list um let's try this okay group by
four that list with first as the
operator it is grouping these elements
by ones that in this case have first
element a first element P okay now if I
were to say at the end here if I were to
say reduction the reduction function
should be length then that's what I
would get right yeah more or less only
the only difference is that II in our
case you have to start from a list of
associations and you have to end with a
list of associations so you you're not
allowed to do all the operations you can
do with group I like you can't do
multiple hierarchical groupings it
always ends up flattened out well let me
understand what flattened out means here
so in this particular case if I were to
take this and I were to ignore this
piece yeah remove it yeah now what what
happens if I just say entity aggregate
by here nothing because it's no it works
like entity class represents the thing
so in this view I have to say in that
value yes but in this case I'm not sure
if and probably you want to put like a
empty list as the third argument because
I'm not sure this is gonna work but what
this does is basically you get yeah it
does work okay so what should I be doing
here no no but it's like not supported
but let's say in D this is the correct
thing so here you result would be a
table that has only one column and
that's type because there's no implicit
aggregation okay so if I just do this
why not why not - I mean first of all
you would you're trying to do something
that it's like you got shadow type
secondly you need an entity function
there the generic Wolfram language code
cannot run on the database
well we should certainly support things
like identity yeah maybe a well identity
here you can't support anything because
identity is not aggregating at all okay
you can also why don't I just say here
if I just say list right yeah that won't
work either because it's not gonna be
increased normal form anymore but I
don't understand what what is okay this
is kind of a mess okay I don't even
understand how this looks what is
positive what is the X that's passed
into the X okay so first you have a gate
so you get a bunch of entities that have
that hard to tight so business read yeah
mod kook popular comp and so on and then
you can go back to the original table
and say for those things that I grouped
I also want to take the total of what
was the price column okay but what is X
X is one entity that's gonna be it's not
right you're right it's that yeah it's
actually the entity class of the yeah
it's the entity class of the entities of
type type sold that have type business
so you could write that's because the
aggregation that's because its
aggregated by tonight yeah yes that's
because it's aggregated by type but you
could write it as entity class type
sorry title comma tied goes to business
and that's the thing that is best there
okay someone from the life
Jim is asking is is entity a great buy
equivalent to with roll-up in SQL no
it's okay um okay so what's that and the
Select not got a select first and then
it's got a group by is that right yes
what an SQL select multiple from
language selection yeah yeah um okay I'm
still not really understanding this very
well um but I want to come back so but
you see what I wanted the pointer was
gonna if you instead of doing any value
now you'd want a list of this then you
will see that now these are indexed by
the type know by now how are you doing
here so I remove that type specification
so now these guys are indexed by the
what an earth is no no no yeah because
you modified the example these here
doing some shadowing called that again
price per type price per type okay what
do you mean by shadowing is that you
called the the aggregate or the same as
the annotation and so they come to help
me what is that turn okay so now if you
look at these the second argument entity
here is an ad type goes to business and
say D type goes to mod cook popular comp
and transport first like this this is an
entity okay that's an entity where's the
entity type there's
the beginning is the Knights entity I
could get because there is no string
type that's on the fly type remember
yeah like another example movie that's
clear because it's made with built-in
entities but it won't work is below if
you look at the underneath examples
there is that good country and continent
so your your your grouping book the
countries by continent and then
completing the creation of the European
countries and so in this case the entity
IDE is Europe
someone from the livestream is asking a
question that I also want to know the
answer to which is why isn't there an
aggregate by 4 data set
well I think that data set as grouped by
which is strictly more powerful but yeah
I mean we should say for data set as
well so the thing is given that we have
a requirement that whatever we end up
with is always sort of a flat table well
for data set they deal with things
differently they construct hierarchical
you know hierarchical structures where
aggregators can be in a different like
deeper level of that structure then we
have so this is a slightly different
semantics right I hate to make a comment
about something this trivial but is it
really right to have lowercase e for
this Pokemon thing I surely bug it's a
bug
ok great yep ok so but easy in this case
were construct we really constructing
new entities that didn't really exist
them before ok let's let's go back up to
the top here so the question that you're
asking is you're trying to make an
entity by aggregation is that right
you're trying to make a kind of pop up
entity by aggregation yes that's correct
hmm ok so then the question is what is
the name of that entity yes okay rather
yeah canonical me really how we index
into that your truth table right well
and perhaps in the world of the future
how would you use natural language to
represent to ask for that entity mm-hmm
ok so clearly the symbolic
representation I mean the code of how
you got to that entity has to be part of
its quotes name yeah I'm the first
argument right so so this stuff here I
understand that the thing you're
describing here is what what is this
stuff this is the base things that comes
yeah these are the things that come from
the built-in tables in the database ok
before you start creating before you
start doing operations on them to
combine things and I go gate things and
so on so I'm correct yeah ok
so in this
database that you've got up here these
these these IDs just came from whoever
created this database correct yes okay
and and this column name came from there
okay so it's table name editor is table
table name okay what what's what's then
the column so far none like I get it do
you really think it's right even when
you've registered the so in this case
you've registered the database
yeah I'm sorry you've registered the
entity store and that allows you to use
a naked string like this what happens if
there's a collision between these things
when you do an entity register Michael I
don't know what no I I think that it's
vinyl at words what's that
I think the last one wins but not I
think that what you can yeah I think
that when we talked about this first one
of the ideas was that you can register a
counter ENT store if you want to say
like I don't know like let's say that
the building entities doesn't don't have
I said you have some crazy idea when
you're going to be able to add another
country that is not that yeah yeah yeah
I understand you're gonna claim that and
this could be a very bizarre decision
but if you have two entities stores a
and B and they both have entities that
are countries that essentially you can
have you know when you say entity of
country you'll get the stuff from the
entity store that corresponds to the one
that actually contains the country with
that canonical name is that correct yeah
that might be a nightmare in terms of
performance but yeah well it might be a
nightmare in terms of not knowing what's
gonna overwrite what because you know
when you put in database be you know
it's gonna randomly overwrite a bunch of
the answer that's not the way to go the
way to go is to use some kind of perfect
scene that would indicate in case of
collisions in disambiguate and tell it
like something like fully qualified
names you know yeah yeah I understand
that it might be useful like to say to
have maybe a more explicit construct to
say please augment building entities
with some temporary entities like
because I found or something very
property because yeah but look the the
key thing here is entity register is
operating kind of a hack I mean what
it's trying to do which is good is it's
trying to reproduce you know if I say
country you know whatever it is it Sally
or something then that the canonical
form of that is just entity like that
right and it's good to be able to let
users create entities that are as simple
as that I think however when you bring
in some random unwashed database from
the outside or seven such databases the
fact that they're random table names
happen to show up here seems wrong to me
yeah but that's so we have two places
where you can fix that one is directly
in the SQL database objects that already
currently supports aliasing for those so
like you can do database inspect and
then go modify that SQL object to to fix
okay
the other place is the empty store
there's in the empty store you have
another level of indirection where you
can say well these unwashed uncouth
database administrator use lowercase
names and I don't like them so you can
like make all the type names remind me
how that were industry so where is the
where is the specification ok so right
now like right now it's not there
documented because that there's no
there's no outside data but what we what
we were planning to do in I don't know
if we've implemented it yet is to have
something that says like biggie so when
you define an entity type the key is the
name of the type and then you can say
but point is stable on the database so
it's gonna be something like there's
gonna be a key inside that says there's
a big stable me ok so so get in here
enter this store um
so inside the data staring inside the
data on the type level will have a field
that will be called something like you
know database table in our case but
maybe we wanted also somehow a general
thing to Alice to disambiguate which
would say rename this or use a different
name for this type yeah I understand I
understand so that but boy I want to
comment for folks on the live stream
this is this is a much more technical
meeting than I thought this was going to
be so we're we're dived pretty deep into
some highly technical things there's a
question here about something completely
different we're taking and we're going
to take a micro break here there's a
question about bioinformatics formats
well that's that's really different um
and most of those do not return most of
those return very simple things like
strings and so on I don't know these
formats that are being specified here we
happen to have a a new initiative in
bioinformatics stuff we can pass that on
to the folks who are working on that
I've never heard of those particular
types I'm actually curious whether they
return database like things or whether
they are like faster for example and
returning basically strings um I'm sure
that I mean diverse woman who takes care
of the bio informatics stuff is also a
bit of his expert so that has happens to
be true yes alright so hopefully
somebody can pass this on to him ok
another point being made here data set
can work on hierarchical tables flatten
tables the flattened
Judy tables are important please think
about having aggregate by in addition to
group by irrespective of entities I I
would actually like to understand that
remark okay so why don't you walk me
through what the difference is between
aggregate by and group by for a dataset
you okay yeah okay
so let's take an example see I think
that's somewhere in that database folder
you have something that is called like
us something with a sock in the name
okay so maybe you take well what do I
have here I thought that I have an
implementation of aggregate by that
works on these results okay well let's
take an example here um just an example
dataset okay if planets now perhaps you
can tell me if I do group by on this on
this dataset what do I get
so there's not much to group on here but
well let's do something let's let's
flatten out let's do okay one way to
this is by first flattening out the
moons by planet okay but so let's in
this aggregate by wouldn't I I mean like
for example if I want to get the total I
mean I know how to do this in other ways
if I want to get the total mass of all
the moons of each planet right that's
support let's suppose you start with a
flattened out table of balloons and each
has a planet so first point you're
making is this thing is not
representable in SQL in a single table
this thing is a hierarchical structure
oh yeah so let's just look just for my
understanding of how I would get so if I
take it's not that you're not
represented in SQL it's just that you
need to represent you have not formed as
UNIX please exactly and then you need to
have somehow a way to extract basic it
is all three with a single query that
that can be done as well that's just the
structure is well-defined
yes right okay so just for my
understanding I want to get the
aggregated mass so for each planet let's
to get on equal footing with what we
were doing
first you need to flatten and the name I
don't want to do that first I want to
understand how we did this in a
hierarchical structure and then we'll
flatten it and and go back and see what
we would do in an SQL way of doing it
okay so if I say all comma moons here
all comma moons comma mass like that
then that should give me what is that
giving me
all planets and the moons there right am
i correct mm-hmm
okay now how do I get for each of those
moons I want to group by I want to group
by the planet and get the masses of the
moons how do I and they're really good
wetlands oh yeah fine okay
oh I see I see so I'd have to flatten it
in order to make it interesting
yeah but so if I just want to get so
tell me how to get the total for each
plan at the total mass of its moons I
just need to use total I guess as the
right so then then the next element is
total if I'm not mistaken but it should
be total of hash of mass I think so what
is it is it at star hash mass or
something yes you can you can probably
use this maybe somebody knows this will
work no that doesn't look right
okay so remind me how to do this so if I
if all I want to do here is to get the
this result but I only want the masses
here do I do this why isn't that giving
me why is that giving me radius as well
do you understand the question you
probably need to insert all and then
mass oh that's right that's right
because for all moons that's right
that's what I'm doing here okay so then
for all moons there that's right that's
what I need right all right exactly so
now here right all planets the moons of
those all those which just gives a list
so now what I should be able to do there
it's just say total like that boom we
got the results cool okay all right so
now let me understand how to do this in
the SQL world
where you've told me I first of all have
to get the flattened list of all moons
that we wrecked yeah we are not either
with the planets what do you mean
annotated you mean you mean with the
planets as a column yes okay you want to
tell me how to do that it would be
useful to see the actual structure that
data set like take a first like it's
it's an association whose outer keys of
the planets then with each within each
planet there's an association which
gives the mass the radius and then the
list of moons and so on that's the
structure so you can I think that's a
very grotesque way to do it you guys
otherwise the plants are only in the
keys I would say you can just say keys
of dataset okay okay so that that thing
has to have the key planet right what
thing has to have the key planet no no
the key is all the planets go no but if
you want flatten it out now this has to
be appended to the moons right let's
first get all the moons like old
Ottomans flattened so that would be yes
old moons and then drawing yes join
moons okay so this will give us join us
at all yeah I can do that actually don't
I want catenate
what do you think that's giving it no
that's wrong it's not it's not easy to
do this way and that's why I actually
wanted to see the Association not with
the formatting but just if you take just
take key like D s of one if one how can
you do normal this okay
well we probably what D s of five or
something yes that's the thing with
actually let's do D s of four that has a
respectable number of movies okay okay
so it gives you the planet name well
actually planet named planet is a key so
it wasn't lost
which is what Carlo was mentioned
dimension but other than that you have
the mass and radius that you are not
interested in and then you have moons so
what you have to do is indeed to do key
value the map well but you have access
you need access to the key right Yuki
Valley map on this thing you can insert
the name of the planet yeah insert the
name of the planets to you - these saw
okay so the claim of someone on the
livestream is that this is unnecessarily
complex because we don't have aggregate
by do we believe this well it's no I
think that this is very complex because
you don't have a good way of flattening
first then then aggregate by it's not
difficult to write this rule by but I
agree with the sentiment that we should
have no fire you mean aggregate by yeah
we should have a great life but we don't
have a way to you know basically take
the headings and append them as as a
color no because that's usually a
grotesque thing to do
I mean the only reason we're doing that
is because SQL is a two dimensional
tables world
which they don't usually have so yes for
a dataset you usually do aggregation
already within these you know sub
structures that have been chosen to
represent it in this particular
hierarchical way which is why dataset is
well-suited for that particular
operation because they simply map on
deeper levels the aggregation functions
and if one aggregate by it's much more
suited to that structures so which is
why it's a bit foreign when we start
from the data set form okay so the thing
that is that the the challenge here is
that basically all the stuff we're
getting from SQL is is have is is in the
form of these flat tables which are not
particularly I mean they can obviously
be converted easily to data sets but
data sets a much richer structures but
ok let's come back to what we're doing
over here um and let's see doing this
for it's worth okay let's say data set
of this thing we know the planet says
common oh okay now we need we also need
to explore the moons so to speak yes
okay I get it and we got to move the
moons down into this next hierarchical
level yeah um let's not let's not take
our time to do this right now okay um
okay but let's come back to what you
were talking about over here which is so
first thing that is an issue is that we
want the convenience of having an entity
that just has a simple string name um
but I'm concerned about the way that
that will actually if you're dealing
with many databases which have
overlapping you know table names and so
on that that will confuse everything so
that suggests even in this case that
there has to be some way when you do the
entity register to tell it that you
either want it to do the kind of base
registration or you want to do some kind
of decorated registration yeah and I
think assume that the raw approach is
already like in database world which
work for problems like that exactly and
they are reminiscent of the fully
qualified name so it's just a matter of
having that thing somehow the database
has an ID in fact the database more than
that it has a symbolic representation
this SQL database object so there's no
reason why we can't just say entity of
you know this SQL database object um you
know for example arrow the the table
name or something for example yeah it
would be I mean I guess that if you do
that you get a very bare ante store
which is like the one we have up there
with entry store of database expect I
mean you lose all ability of really we
should have entity of anti store a role
table me okay no but probably still your
problem and during the registration not
during the referring to entities no it
both things I mean look I mean once you
if you register it okay if you do an
entity register that is you know look
you can okay clearly in our system you
can say you know plus equals something
or other right you can you can well
actually that won't work because it's
protected but you know you could
unprotect it and blow everything up um
but
there has to be the possibility in
principle of registering something which
will overwrite country right yeah so one
question I would have here is whether it
would not be better to just use string
names for registration as a liasing you
know like you say this under this name
this database
you also want Wireless column names in
properties
yes but that's a separate that's a
separate issue that you want to rename
you know you don't control them and you
know and use those names that you want
basic you can refer to you know I mean
you you you want to maybe use the
English name because you don't know
Spanish so you need to be able to do
this kind of stuff okay
that's happening at the level of the
entity store right you can map in in the
entity store can you map the native
property names to your property names
yes that work well we so far we can do
it for in our particle implementation
there is a place in the SQL database
object where you can indicate that for
table names and there is a place in the
first argument of the resulting entity
store where it can indicate that for for
a column names but we don't have any way
to rename the entire entity store so to
speak okay another thing that you want
also in you know those boxes that is
here when you do entity means I mean
most databases what will happen is that
a lot of table got just incremental ID
and so you will end up by doing query in
different tables and you only see one
two and three because basically normally
in a database this is how you got
primary hints and so they will all look
the same and so you also need like some
function that allows you to format the
box is there and and and we need to take
care to map it efficiently but but you
know there are all kinds of
customization there are different ways
that whether we
we've got an entity store you can
specify the labels that actually appear
here right
yes this is already implemented or no
you're suggesting that there should be
some kind of labeling function which is
a programmatic way of going from the raw
keys I mean the key might be irrelevant
for you to give you the information
I mean inbuilt identities you you have
this pretty thing where a basic your
country and then the string in Italy
that is empty like that but that doesn't
happen with databases they just have the
number one so probably relevant for you
and you want to take out and put this
place on some information about well in
this case I mean you want to dive deeper
into the actual values well look at look
at this case of the auditory in this
case you have editor first name and then
this or last name so my guess is that
the label would be three join where is
the same space listening saying is that
the labeling function that when you
specify when you set up the entity store
the labeling function should be able to
reach in and grab value right is that
already set up in Anstey store yes yes
yes
so I didn't ready a limit function right
now well actually the way to do it is
that there is a labeled property and
that label property has a default
function okay
default function to
the value of this property so if you
think yeah not wait so that label is a
sub property of the property because
property also if labels
so yes look at this is the end I'm
talking about here yeah yeah yeah no
wait no that's the label to use in
displaying the type yes so here we go
yeah label for the entity type okay yeah
so all of these can either label and all
the labels can have a default function
so we're are you sure I thought only
values could have default functions know
what properties canonical functions and
sub properties can see oh I see and
label is just a property yeah okay it's
so you're saying then that that the
default function could reach in and pull
out your editor first name last name
yeah I display if the type level
property can have a default function
probably not or maybe can have only a
default function because there's no data
associated with the whole type okay all
right fine so that's the question of so
okay so we've got several things here
we've got when you set up the entity
store what when you do this particular
thing you're just saying entities store
of database inspect what that's doing is
it's using the defaults for all of the
that's just using defaults for all of
the the whole you know sequence of
looking at schemas looking at tables etc
it's just using that if I'm not mistaken
yeah yeah and there's a lot more stuff
you can do to start doing 20 so for
example imagine that these stuff has my
for example here we have prices things
like that okay but as a prime language
you want it but you want units attached
to that so yeah the aunt you okay so as
a practical matter it'd be nice to see
for this example what this actual entity
register should look like I mean it's
probably gonna have four lines of stuff
that map for every one of these things
like editor it's going to have some kind
of mapping about labels etc etc etc and
then my next question is if I was going
to do this you know in practice what I
would probably want to do is to take
they do database inspect get out some
Association here and start editing it to
add different things for that mapping
well that actually the interesting thing
is that basically when you evaluate an
entity store around SQL database object
we generate like a skeleton version of
the first argument of the entity store
so you can edit that so if you instead
of like just evaluate the engine storing
that entity register and you can see
what gets out what enter this store ok
so what what's your point here I mean I
really like that so basically what so
you already have kind of a skeleton
structure to fill in no a that's not you
don't need to go Remagen to the SQL
database object and by the way just came
to my mind another idea that rather than
editing direct content of this we might
as well support another you know
function or a wrapper that would take
this skeleton and only add things that
are changed that have been changed and
it will kind of merge it with this
skeleton you know this is a way of I
mean in the entity register one could
expect to give a list just like show or
something does that for graphics one
could expect to give essentially the
updates to those options yes yes that's
what I've more or less what I mean what
I mean
and is there a problem in doing that in
an entity register shouldn't be I don't
know it should maybe we should wait for
Tony to decide this kind of stuff maybe
he has good reason why not
yeah but can we like we have like about
half an hour left
can we go back I'm trying to understand
ok so the first step here is the as
you're calling them the base type basic
types right yes so there are things
which come directly from the names of
tables in the database yes there are
things that somehow come from multiple
columns so what is this entity ID right
so there are two ways of of thinking
about this either it's completely
positional or it's an association and
cannot be an Incan Association but but
either way what's wrong with saying is
do we have some conflict with saying you
know whatever it is the the entity here
and yes this could be a fully qualified
name here that goes from that database
connection object yeah okay Tara Tara so
this is the
that is giving the okay so this is the
database connection object goes to some
schema probably how are the schemas
named no database wait no it's database
SQL database object easy schema okay yes
this isn't a database SQL object to
something another arrow or something I
don't know if it's an arrow to the table
name so that correct yeah I mean I would
prefer to at the entity store in the
first argument is that it is much
feature but so you're saying okay so
you're saying the fully qualified form
here but how do you reference the answer
D store you're saying the actual
entities to the actual object why don't
I mean it's not that much bigger than
the SQL database object what went it
what's the actual entity store which has
the database object there yeah this is
not a reference to the entity store it's
the actual entity store yes okay if you
don't want to registry that's anyway I
see what women if you don't register it
then you could just I see that's a good
reason to actually put the energy store
in there I think we had that as a plan
okay so that's the entity store so now
the question is what is the no you can't
no no you can't just put the end to the
story there why not
because there are stories in multiple
tables okay so what do you what do you
think yeah I still need to do our table
name
well arrow type yeah sure
okay so then and then you can all have a
list of positional things or you have an
entity ID that represent Association of
mean things fine but but those things
represent in the entity store it has
these names of entities right
and those are the names that you have to
refer to things by here yes and the
slightly confusing thing is that the
entity store by the time it's an entity
store why hasn't it resolved all these
questions about multiple why hasn't it
by this point by the time it's an entity
store you've already resolved this
question I mean this question the
question is not whether it's resolved by
any store it's what we decide to me it
looked like no no I understand that but
that means but then the question here is
okay so this is whatever the name is in
the entity store is the name that
appears here well no no no wait wait
with it is the entry store when you
construct the NC story if you go up then
this sword doesn't have an immediate
knowledge of values of the entities that
exist as a matter of fact you might be
connected to a database that does 1000
transactions per second and so the
entities pop in and out of existence all
the times we don't download them so the
names are not in the end store they are
only in the database on the NC story you
know what columns correspond to the
nodes
so the names are already values Steven
values of you know the data that exists
in the database so what you're
effectively saying is that the default
function which defines the names in the
entity store is that correct yeah more
or less
it's it's not default function doesn't
seem like the good thing the good name
to me because different function means
oh if you don't find the value then use
this in this case it's really the names
of the properties that who tries the
primary main know to compose the primary
key so in other words still on this the
the name has two parts there is a meta
information which tells which columns we
need to know the names of those columns
and there is the actual information
which means for that particular entities
what are the values for those columns
let's say actually let's take a simple
example if you think imagine we are
connecting to a database of country
let's say from from the word bank and
they decided to index them as ISO codes
so what you know is that the property
ISO code is the primary key and that's
the only thing you have in the entity
store is primary key goes to least ISO
code close list yeah so um you have the
reference to the column but make no but
listen listen listen look look our
entities have the form type comma name
okay now what you're saying is in an
entity store the name can be
programmatically computed from the
database from the connected database
correct absolutely yes okay so that's
all I'm saying is that that entity store
if you want that name to be a
programmatically computed name then use
a default function for the name in the
entity store you know before default
function is a thing that is defined as
if you can find the value you use the
value otherwise use this default
function in this case there is only the
default function
that's why I'm not happy with okay fine
fine whatever you want to call it but I
mean basically there is something in the
entity store set up that okay so soon
there is one distinction here this is
something we have to decide on and we
are not going to change this or let the
users to change this while for default
function and other things it assumes
some kind of customized ability I don't
understand what you're talking about
look what has to happen is you've got in
the database you've got some you know
names that are being given as you point
out those can be dynamically the actual
objects in the database can be
dynamically changing okay so we need a
mapping from those names in the database
to the names that we use for our
entities that mapping should be in the
specification of the entities store no
because people help edit it in case they
make it a mapping that is not invertible
for example then you're out of luck if
you're using like if the mapping becomes
like string take anything only the first
three characters then those might not be
unique anymore you cannot in goes I can
get the wrong so you set it up wrong and
the entity store do it again but you
shouldn't I mean there's not there's not
much that people can do the only thing
you can do is say well actually it's
something that is deeply into the SQL
database object yes you cannot mess with
them if the NT store otherwise you
cannot retrieve data anymore so it
shouldn't be like user definable all
right so what your point is that that
mapping that name has to be has to have
one-to-one correspondence to the actual
when you type in a name there it has to
be clear what actual thing to go
retrieve in the database absolutely
therefore your point is that that
canonical name has to be a an
essentially trivial mapping it has to be
a guaranteed invertible mapping to the
set of keys that are used in the
database absolutely okay so what's wrong
with the scheme you have it why does it
need and okay because I have two schemes
and and you see that one has advantages
and the other like when you start
nesting these things the hierarchical
one becomes very quickly unreadable
and so another option is to have entity
ID and then basically flatten it at each
time and so their old name they're all
flattened it's easy to read but it's too
verbose for the simple cases so I the
point of this meeting was like deciding
which one we like best but I have to
note also that the second method the
verbosity can be alleviated by the boxes
by the proper formatting yeah entities
are formatted so you don't really see it
all the time but yes this is only all
swapping like for a complex query I mean
most design table get one primary key
and that's it happening I work with
composite kids or look as a practical
matter what's gonna happen here is that
somebody you know given some corporate
database somebody is going to go to a
fair amount of trouble to build these
mappings it's gonna take some time to
build the mappings the you know that's a
separate activity from the use of the
mappings and you know these kinds of
deeply verbose entity specifications
nobody will ever type one of these
things absolutely but someone might want
to read them because you're saying oh
which order is this oh it's the ordered
Aidid on the fifth of January and it's
the second choice absolutely but that
means that as you've said multiple times
the label which has to have a labeling
function which can go in and actually
look at values has to show for the
entity some kind of reasonable display
that comes from applying the labeling
function to the contents to information
in the database from the entity it also
but it also means that the second method
is preferred because it is more
descriptive in terms of what is which
which column it also provides column
names so I would vote for the second
method
well a bunch of reasons why do we have
to choose between these methods I mean I
don't understand that when you set up
the mapping in the entity store that's
not that's not a mapping that will let
the user set the
the label yes but this is too
fundamental if there is too many ways in
which you can make it go around and
especially once you start building on
the fly types with aggregations and
stuff like that then you can specify
thing and store because it has to come
just from query in other words is going
to be wired in into the entity framework
and it's has to be only one way which we
have to decide well okay so your point
is if it's coming raw from the database
so I don't even know how you specify
that you are going to use multiple
columns as the primary key how is that
specified you don't you read it from the
schema okay so the schema contains that
information so where do we where do we
represent that information here okay so
if you look at the boxes but it's in the
input form of this simple form you can
feed I also you can occupy say the input
form of this thing
okay well the bottom go to the bottom
there is a second argument there which
is self yeah after all these tables
descriptions there is this see the first
argument
yeah primary key constraint Lee oh yes
so for example for for let's say title
author my let's look at publisher here
now publisher okay so it's publisher ID
the primary key is the columns of least
the publisher ID so it can be multiple
columns in this case it's one okay but
so this is the thing you are picking up
whatever that specification is for
primary key and what is constraint name
it's if in the database one game that
constraint this is Possible's okay
constraints on the data whatever the
primary key is here
you need that whole thing or some
representation of the whole thing to
give the canonical name for the entity
isn't that correct yes yeah okay so why
isn't it just whatever this is why isn't
why don't you just pull out whatever you
have in this database connection object
and we don't know we don't need all of
that stone we only need the columns why
the content is only relevant when you
modify the database maybe I don't need
to know that that is that it's
modifiable once we have out the entity
well that's not perversion one okay but
we're not designing just reversion one
straight name it's all listening in that
volume some data pages for example here
is non videos I don't think that I feel
like an unmade bed but imported ads you
know this thing is a primary key and I
mean 30 between this check this whole
frame and must be an much seven name in
some databases that way not so Ricardo
you're a bit hard to hear so I repeat so
for example you can have something that
says that that bird that the primary key
is an integer and it's positive so if
you try to insert something that is
negative the database will complain and
I'm a psycho constraint name that seems
the wrong name because because it's an
int function in the database it runs on
the database so but why is it called
constraint name because because when
it's there it's just gonna be a string I
say it's a particular type of constraint
which is just some you know joke by
numbers type you have a particular
string and that's what it does exactly
okay okay but this column's thing so
what is the reason so if you were going
to use an association rather than a list
of columns what would the first element
what would the keys in the Association
be these names publisher ID and the
other possible names for the those are
the keys and then then you have a value
for each entity basically I see I see
okay
we raise this to the level of the ante
store that is going to be call them say
conical name goes to entity property
editor
not sorry publisher publisher ID right I
don't know whether this entity ID is
necessary I think I think it is a good
idea to represent the column names here
if there's more than one column that is
being used as the primary key there it
seems like a good idea now particularly
wait when you create these composites I
don't know whether the answer hold on
let's ask Alan about cases where we are
taking external reference type
information what is the current plan for
this structure of external reference
the current design for that was external
rex ternal identifier yeah okay I was
yes right external identifier first
argument would be the the name of the
the external source I mean we just had
that as a as a string because for the
moment we were thinking it would just be
some set of sources that we have some
canonical representation some kind of
testing database ID you know protein
database right ii ii arg some whatever
unique identifier and then possibly an
association of other assorted stuff that
we might want to pack into the
identifier which could be a name label
whatever conventions we want to use or
but we're canonicalizing by the time we
got source and identifier we think that
is that is the sufficient to represent
the canonical thing and the rest of it
is just decoration is that true or is
the is that is that third element also
supposed to actually be part of
specifying what thing we're talking
about the third animal element was only
additional information that might be
useful to pass in that symbolic form
without having all the data of the
the thing right so in this case the
analog of that would be to pass
information that gives for example
labeling information right here in this
entity as a as a as a as a by the way
associated with the entity and we're
making sense rather than having to put
the labeling externally and have you
know yeah this will be a packaging of
the entity with its labeling rather than
putting the labeling as separate
information in the entity store you know
if the labeling is programmatic and it's
a labeling function then that you know
fits well into the entity store but if
there is a separate labeling for every
entity it's kind of bad to have to give
those I think to be forced to give those
separately relevant packaging with the
entities yeah it makes sounds
particularly because then you don't have
to compute it separately you always kind
of get it by the definition of the
entity itself does entity itself have a
third argument story or not so we could
in principle pack random commentary into
the third argument of the entity one of
the big changes we made going for the
presentation and moving it all to the
properties also tend to the entities do
you mean the decorative chunk yes well
there is one thing we could do which
would save everything which means I mean
if we use entity on ot of label in the
first argument to entity then that's a
place where you can put the label
function why are you putting it in the
first argument why is it not good
because it's part of the query so you're
saying you're not saying first argument
what you're saying and by the way I
can't stand the name entity annotate but
didn't we come up with a better name
well there is a whole discussion to be
had about the names of this because you
wanted now instead of verbs but well
these are the working ones I thought
we'd agreed entity selection and things
like that yeah but we haven't made those
changes yet okay fine but did we come up
with a better name for esterday annotate
we had something what was it
be great if we could remember that - it
should I go look I mean it just would
help me in terms and it was something in
the spirit of a pent you know entity
anyway okay so we'll need that maybe
Dominic knows that should be in the
notes I can look here well anyway so
there is there is another thing that we
we should discuss I think no but XO the
concept here is if you want to put
random decorative junk in with the
entity just like you can build up a
composite symbolic you know operation
has been done on sensitive thing using
things like entity aggregate by you're
suggesting using the annotation symbolic
annotation as a way of adding that stuff
yeah because because if you have
annexation and that is capital L label
then that will automatically work
someone on the livestream is Drake
organic is saying entity extend and I
think I seem to remember that was the
name we came up with or extension me me
it was yes yes that's right very good
thank you
somebody else is asking about
connectivity with CouchDB anybody want
to comment on that is couch DB SQL no
it's no a scale so it's much closer to
data set we can't comment on this at
this point well we have quite separately
connectivity to [ __ ] that's actually
part of eleven three yes there is no
design so far of call to represent
entities that are based on Noah scale
databases well apart from the audience
now yes but it's not the answer is it's
complicated and we have support for data
set we have support coming from sparkle
we have support coming for we have
support now for MongoDB and we're doing
this SQL stuff so the answer is the
answer is that remains a whole yeah that
remains a whole
but maybe it's the whole is not the
right shape because since since it's no
SQL then it read doesn't have tables and
columns and and so it doesn't quite fit
in twenty T's and properties so maybe
data set is a better interface with kind
of yes this is one this is one thing and
the other is even if we started doing
this for entities trying to approximate
that will face a problem that properties
would have to have sub properties and so
on and so on to represent this
adequately and the entity store
currently doesn't have that well it has
some properties but only one that would
not yes that's what I'm saying
and for for hierarchical structures it's
better half of the time and entity store
is a different play from data set which
is a much more general thing that can
support arbitrary hierarchy which is
closer to what this couchdb thing is yes
there was another thing that I wanted to
discuss which is okay it's kind of a
philosophical question so suppose you
have done a select so you filtered the
entities and now otherwise known as
entity selection is that correct yes so
imagine you have done a selection and
you're taking all the books that are
cost more than $20 and then you have a
single entity that is one of these books
just question is if the book goes on
sale does that single entity still exist
or not if it stops costing more than
twenty dollars like this whole scheme of
putting the qui in the first argument
would mean that no entity doesn't exist
in more be is now cheaper so it's not
part of that there are some parts of
that selection yes
the reason why we are asking this
student is that the current one of the
questions we are up to is whether we
should always put the entire query as a
first argument as the type of the entity
and this example is in favor of yes we
have to do it because this will
differentiate between entities which are
from the original one and the entities
which are from the selected one I mean
if you delete an entity with a primary
key the point is it's a lazy thing I
mean that is you've got this symbolic
representation that represents the way
you extract the entities that correspond
to this type so the type is dynamic
exactly we have a precedent that says no
really because if you take entity if you
take the entity list of the entity class
of GG 8 countries and then you evaluate
that in a notebook three years later you
come back you open that notebook and say
Italy is kicked out of the g8 and and
slow being hazing then what happens I
mean should should the references to
those entities have a memory of the fact
that they came out of a query that was
an s-class okay so the question is those
entities right now only say country they
don't say that we were in the g8 right
as opposed to what you're saying for the
thing we're talking about now where
you're imagining that everything is lazy
yes of the actual entity specification
itself yes so actually this example just
shows that entity list
in sense is a wrong thing in this energy
framework in that it's too eager and it
creates this kind of tension okay but
listen guys at some point it has to
resolve I mean you could be any value
well I know but what's happening here is
that entity list like entity value is
doing a resolution of some kind yes
right it's actually basically entity
value of the primary keys yeah well I
mean this seems useful and I
I think the question of whether one
wants a lazy form of entity list is a
different thing yeah that's right
probably for this particular thing it
will be enough if all these entities
that you see on the screen would
remember the original query they came
from so that if something happens later
they could sort of say that okay I no
longer exist because things changed I
don't believe it I don't believe in that
but that's good you know you're gonna
maintain this whole giant trail of all
kinds of weirdness for that I mean at
some point it has less weirdness because
the thing is that imagine you're doing
something very complicated where it is
selection is not the outermost operation
but it's deep inside other operations
that are more structural yes well that
you can't just say okay we peel off a
few of the ANSI selections if we can we
peel off sort by and instant class but
not all the other things because they're
structural and then
in my opinion if you say oh you have a
query you don't see Lister you have this
nice identity that the first argument
was watch fast once this it's very easy
to understand someone from our live
streams is saying you have to track all
the entities origins and interest in
climb I mean what you're saying as well
right so I mean the issue here is
you know within our own knowledge base
you know this this question that you're
raising here namely that the entities
that are returned from entity list this
is a result you know in other words
and the fact that were you to recompute
this at some point in the future you
might get a different result that's fine
it is not the case that everything in
the system is lazy enough that will you
to compute it I mean if I would say now
for example then in my notebook there's
the result for now is right there if I
were to open this notebook again I mean
if I were to say dynamic of now then it
will be a whole different story
right but if I just say now then you
know it's evaluated at the time when
it's evaluated and it gets the result it
gets different that's why okay let's
let's do kind of okay so let's forget
for a second about entity selection and
see class and it's sort by entity
annotate is something that you cannot
get the properties now today I don't
have it and if you go ahead it's
something that you cannot do anymore
if you if you don't have the extension
in the first argument because you don't
know how to compute it you know you lose
the property that you have extended
right yeah you don't know what yes but
wait a second okay the issue is okay
these entities that you're dealing with
that are associated with an external
database their existence is tied to
whatever the external database says is
the case so to speak yes but it's not
only this it's there is a much simple
problem if you have a set of books and
then you filter those books by the price
so only give me books which are cheaper
than ten dollars then one in the same
book can be in the first set but it
costs $15 so it's not in the second so
the question is when I'm getting from
one and say like the same entity of the
same type one filtered and one not then
one of them exist and one and the other
one should not
reflected but wait wait a second
learning before we get into that like
there are a series of operation where we
can't get around putting the Cree in the
first argument like if you're doing a
joint across if you're doing an
aggregate by if you're doing even just
an OT extend then there's no way to take
the properties out unless you put the
whole queer in the first argument so
there is there is just a small subset of
things that you can peel away if you
want and my question is do we really
want to document the weird algebra of
these had they said in this other hand
can be peeled out but only if they are
the outermost if they're inside no
because then it changes the whole result
I want to come back to the main point
okay
the main point is that at some moment
you actually resolve from whatever was
in the database you go through and you
compute and the answer is seventy-five
or something right if you want to find
out what that answer is two days later
you recompute it right so at some point
everything resolves yes question is but
the entity a list of entities is not
completely resolved because you can
still pass it 22 value and get values
out I'm aware but you know as you've
said that list of entities you might
have a different list of entities two
days later because some property of some
entity changed and so a selection an
upstream selection when run would give a
different results right yes
but the idea that you're going to
maintain everything and I don't even
think it's correct to maintain
everything in a lazy form in other words
I think it's perfectly reasonable to say
if you want to know what this result is
today computed again right that's fine
that's fine Steven but there are some
results that you can't possibly retrieve
like for example lightly if you scroll
down and look at the examples for
joining across yeah like those examples
just structurally different so so what
and so you need to represent the
structure in some way otherwise you
don't know how to retrieve them what do
you mean by retrieve you mean how to do
the actual lookup admit I look at look
at okay
examples there's one with country and
city so you're joining the the countries
with the cities and you're joining on
the capital so you're you're adding the
you reading the the whole capital bill
like Rome three three so you can get the
nation of Rome you can get mayor of Rome
or whatever I hate the way databases
work anyway never mind as well databases
it's so good tasks okay go on now the
question is like there's no way around
between a giant cross in the first
argument because otherwise the second I
mean it doesn't make sense we don't we
don't even have a name for this joined
table I understand I understand and if
you go further down there is a super
complex example that has annotations in
the middle and then joined this gray one
so this one is computing but it's taking
a subset of all the books that it's
taking the authors it's computing the
total income per author of of each book
which the author so how much money let's
just summarize what you're saying okay
the the basic question is how much stuff
is lazily maintained in the
specification of the entity versus how
much stuff resolves and one of the
conflicts is that even to say what
entity you're talking about you need to
maintain a bunch of stuff yes yes
and there is only so much you can peel
like this case you can peel nothing
because there's no outer entity select
or entity sorry yeah and it's deflection
or entity class okay so what you're
saying is the
as you do a bunch of operations those
operations are maintained in symbolic
form we've agreed about that I'm still
confused when the idea I think is simple
I mean you need to think about the stuff
like entity class contract you you just
create new types at runtime
and and the only way to maintain those
those those type without creating side
effect is that the whole thing is is the
type is considered the type and and you
put it inside entity and now you use
that to resolve entity value so it's
really all those countries all those
constructs are Antony glass like you're
effectively generating a new type that
in step and it depends to the
coalition's of not meeting a new type
and sorry I finish but if you start
saying this operation is not creating a
new type what is the type and those kind
of stuff these are discussion that
basically is never never ends
yeah you gotta make exceptions for
things this has the advantage that it
has no acceptor and and at least improv
let's look at each one knows what I'm
suppose it's basically you can try to to
summarize it Carlo
okay you're very hard to hear so yeah so
what we can't be seeing is that what I
was saying before is that I mean if you
decide if you want to make a call that
some things get peeled off then you
start getting combined I realize I
understand that it's a slippery slope
and it doesn't seem like the right thing
and by the way it's doing we already
discussed this all and I think we
already kind of agreed on the run time
type I mean Tony is still become defense
about yeah that's right well the fact
that Tony isn't here is kind of bad yeah
um this has been a bit of a frustrating
meeting as far as I'm concerned I mean
there's a complicated subject and I'm
confused that she somebody on the
livestream is is saying that they
recommend creating a repository and not
put everything on the entity level
because now entity can do apparently
everything not quite understanding that
um that's not possible with the Lexus
with the degree of laziness and symbolic
nature of entities unfortunately because
they are too lazy to not know they have
to know a bunch about themselves to to
to be as lazy as we want them to be yeah
Janek is pointing out that that tables
have types and operations on tables
create new types and so you need to type
algebra which is kind of what we you
know that's kind of the type of thing we
have here now in fact we have a whole
different type algebra system that
think is closely related to this
unfortunately I mean the type algebra
that's used in that's being used in
things like the compiler and so on it's
a different one and I don't think it's
it's bad to have several type systems
because they always belong to a
particular problem they're sold yeah
well this is really not that this is a
relational algebra and that one is like
more a Hindley Miller type of algebra so
not quite the same structure
mathematically okay but but let's just
I'm sorry I'm just we need to kind of
wrap this up and I'm you know the
original question that you were asking
is deceptively simple relative to the
actual story here yeah and I think your
answer is let's use entity ID and
Association unless it's a single thing I
don't know whether we need the entity ID
wrapper we we actually do because of so
since we have implicit entities at the
second argument the second argument of
an entity is a list of rules it does
some very specific thing there is not
this one and so if we need a brother now
wait wait if this one introduced a rule
where an association does a different
thing subtly different thing than a list
of rules now I think that's been asked
so we need a wrapper maybe it's not in
CD I mean if you want like to have a
generic ID object for example things
like create uu ideas now returning a
stranger they state they could have been
reserving some kind of ID that unit is a
generic object idea so that is not a
thing and the idea is actually the
expression and and for that the
expression would be I understand but as
soon as we do that know that that's
silly because basically you know that's
going to turn into just an arbitrary
symbolic expression
this know we need the specific one yeah
so I don't know whether the name entity
ID is right I don't think it is but fine
but then the main point here is that
these types can be these arbitrarily
complicated database operations
basically referring it's not only
database still on this should also work
for the memory back-end as well so it's
a general construct no I understand but
at the end of at the end of this
somewhere it is referring how is it
referring somehow the whole thing has to
refer to the connection object the
registration registration which I don't
think is necessarily the right thing
well if you if you want then before
title author before title before author
I know you'd end up having to have it
some grotesque thing with the connection
object right or as an option Stephen
that could be registered as a string
name that could be okay listen this is
the same thing we're getting an entity
function entity function is an attempt
to take what are effectively string
names and make them make it so that
right so I mean no it's much more than
that stirrin well I understand that yeah
it avoids the fact so the fact that this
naked string represents something I mean
in principle you could end up with two
database connections here that you're
referring to in your in your weird join
across then that have names that
actually conflict right but they are
disambiguated by value we know I realize
that but I'm saying that these these
names these naked names that you're
using here could might need to be
qualified with the database connection
that they come from yes okay but the
entity store the only representation
that we currently have for an entity
store is the symbolic entity store it's
self whereas the database connection is
an opaque object the entity store itself
is just until it's registered at which
point it's types then appear as string
names basically the entity store itself
does not have a an opaque object that
represents it it is just represented by
itself as a symbolic thing yeah but
still my point is that in theory you
could have one database connection and
construct two completely different there
is a store around it changing the names
and we all sorts of weird stuff and so
the right level of specification there
is the insist or not the database
connection because you can have more
people at least or database connection
no I understand but I'm saying how do
you reference the entity store other
than by just giving the whole entity
store um you could give it a name when
you register and then you're registering
the name of the entity store you've got
two levels of registration then no the
other thing is that he could optionally
and the store could have like an option
that says name goes to a string and then
no I understand but then then you could
have the situation of two entities
stores with the same string name no
register should basically fail if you
try and register to entity stores of the
same name yes exactly
if you don't just the only option is
that you usually the energy storage
sauce right so none of these things none
of these names here like title would
work if you hadn't registered the entity
store yeah yes there's something wrong
with this I mean that is that the I mean
one of the things that's probably wrong
is that within an entity store that you
get to register multiple types with
naked names like this why do you
consider this wrong well because I think
what's confusing about it is that
somehow
you know you're saying we'll use a
single string to represent the entity
store because it's easier to notice that
you have two entities stores with the
same name than that some particular
random type inside one entity store yes
with some random type inside another
entity store yes right that's some I
mean it makes one think that the better
scheme would just be to say okay great
we can give a name to enhance this store
and then the more qualified name for the
type is entity store name arrow type
name yes exactly I think it will be
still useful to allow people to use a
single string no I agree this is nice it
looks nice to have a single string it
also allows one to use the kind of hash
notation for you know to use that to
pull that out of an association by the
way this use of underscores and
databases I mean it might be useful for
us to end up with some convention for
dealing with even some bizarre syntactic
thing where where if you do a hash
because clearly we can't support those
underscores as such in our syntactic
system with you know hash in front of
the whole thing but so far we don't
support hash in front of the whole thing
and no I understand not with underscores
on it no I mean also like I think it is
already if you want to know like in
entity function like hash is documented
to be just for association and if you
wanted to use it for an entity bound no
you couldn't use it for any function it
has a very definite meaning it's it's
it's hash you know Open bracket name
that's what hash name means right that's
that's it's precisely equivalent to that
well you'll have to walk over enticed
and button to get that through but
because it's it's it's really not
functional application there it's it's
or Association extraction it's really
entity value and in every size no I know
I know so okay all right let's not cross
that particular bridge right now okay we
are really out of time um
this has been a slightly frustrating
meeting for those as I say on that
livestream this is more technically
complicated and I mean I'm I'm still a
little bit unclear what I mean yeah we
really need to go through again okay it
appears to be the case there is no
choice but to build up these sort of
lazy symbolic objects as they're kind of
composite pop-up entity types right that
appears to be what we have to do yes um
the details of exactly how that works I
mean I would like to understand more how
these operations work I'd also like to
get a more realistic a few more
realistic examples of what the mapping
tables look like effectively in other
words take some real database I don't
know our bugs database or something and
actually try and write what this um you
know what the realistic sort of
convenience so you want play both in
there and maybe even I think so I mean
let's see what it looks like and see see
what this
I mean basically what we're dealing with
is what this structure looks like for a
realistic database right well this
database we are showing here is quite
realistic except for being small fine
fine I understand it's realistic but you
haven't decorated it here yes right I
mean you haven't got realistic label
names and things like that I'd like to
see what that actually looks like and
then you know the question really is
from a management point of view you know
in a typical corporate setting there'll
be a bunch of random corporate databases
these mapping tables want to be also
stored centrally somewhere so what is
our plan for doing that instead I'm
saying I mean it's not gonna be in some
one sort of pop-up notebook that these
appear most of the time so it will be
this is the database we're connecting to
and we always want to connect with this
mapping table if I so here is here is
the ideas doing when you do entity
register
one of the ways is remember we're
discussing that they could could in
principle take a second argument that
would be the mapping that will be the
decoration and that could also be a file
pointing to a certain file where that
thing is you know really located okay
but but realistically we need to think
through what this actually looks like so
you know take our company for example
with whatever it is thousands of random
databases around the company right each
one has like the point of the database
some authentication information and this
mapping table that anybody who's going
to use it from or from language it's
going to need write that mapping table
is presumably made by you know DBAs
effectively or something like that one
would hope it's made by DBAs that that
and the question is where is that and
what does the thing look like when you
make this connection is it something
where it's proxying something through
the cloud that there is some cloud
object that contains all that connection
information together with this table or
what needs a separate discussion I think
right but I mean then the question is
you know what would be convenient like
in our corporate setting it's just like
we have you know the data repository it
will be useful to have maybe it's even
you know we we have you know a private
data repository within the company and
which contains data of use within the
company and a question is is it that
data repository is it is it a private
data repository like that that contains
the references you know in resource data
like things contains these accessible
databases together with all their
mapping tables or is there some separate
repository that contains that
information by making sense well we've
already put these stores in memory and
three stores in the in the data
repository that's right
so that's right I mean I I don't see why
we couldn't have like some sort of
curated entity store well in the data
repository that doesn't actually contain
data file it contains the connection to
an external SQL I agree I
maybe that's right let's walk through
that I mean let's try to build what the
data repository entry if it is the data
repository for example for the bugs
database let's try and build you know
just so we're clear what you know what
the goal would be I mean if we take you
know a typical if we take I really am
late for something else but but um
[Music]
that's not what I'm looking for data
repository okay so if I go to the data
repository that's just the external data
repository and I go to I don't know I
think we have one here for example um
there's a good example here um yeah this
one I think oh that's a database there
but I think there's also an entity store
of that um maybe we should have entity
store okay all right so here we go so
this is an entity store right so the
question is can I get it so that and
that is totally grotesque contributor
replaced by a entity register is that
that that should be like that's a
separate history oh good Owen yeah Tara
no just to saying yes I see that right
um
so my question then is you know what I'd
like to see is a page like this that
says this is how to connect to the bugs
database as a as an entity store and
then you know with somehow the backend
of this being all of this mapping table
and so on right does that make sense to
people yeah yeah except that we also
have to decide to what extent we really
want to always save in the schema
because depending on whether the
database itself is like you know
read-only or not we might actually want
to either store this scheme or say that
it has to be inspected every time too
[Music]
Changez even though the first argument
fencing story will have to change yeah
okay so so figure that out but the end
result should be we need something that
looks like this which is both for our
you know sort of personal internal
purposes and for everybody else to be
able to have their corporate databases
to be you know visible in a nice clean
way like this student go browse them and
go find one and go see how to do the
connection makes sense yeah all right we
should wrap up for right now and hope
for a simple meeting next time and okay
yeah actually I didn't even notice that
right the fact that the the fact that
the computations were actually working
is a very good sign and yes that is good
thank you for pointing out that that
uptick of fact and thanks to people on
the livestream who had all sorts of
sophisticated things to say and
appreciate that for those who are
interested later on this afternoon we
are doing a meeting on a completely
different topic about geometry and
invite you all all and but is interested
to join that okay thanks all see you
later